SPEAKER: Welcome to this
episode of "Click to Deploy,"
a series where we
show you how easy it
is to deploy a solution from
the Google Cloud Marketplace.
In this episode,
we'll showcase how
to set up an Elasticsearch
and data flow integration
via the Cloud Marketplace.
Elastic Cloud now has
native integration
with Google Cloud
Dataflow, which
provides customers with
easy and fast data ingestion
into Elastic Cloud.
Now data from BigQuery, Pub/Sub,
and Google Cloud Storage
can be directly adjusted to
Elastic via Google Dataflow.
Let's start by searching for
Elastic in the marketplace.
We'll choose the solution
labeled Elastic Cloud.
On the Solution page,
make sure to read
through the overview, pricing,
and support to learn more
about the solution.
Pricing for the solution is
billed monthly or annually,
based on your subscription plan.
You'll notice the
pricing calculator,
which will allow you to model
your estimated monthly cost.
Start by selecting a plan.
We'll keep the default plan.
Next, choose the
correct billing account.
Then, make sure to review
the terms of the contract.
If you approve of them, agree
to the additional terms,
which are about
billing and complying
with the license agreement.
Finally, click the Subscribe
button to launch the solution.
Now let's move on to the
next step, which is managing
your subscription with Elastic.
You'll need to register
with an Elastic account
to manage the solution.
Sign up or log in to
your Elastic account.
On Elastic Cloud, you can
create your own deployment.
A deployment includes
Elasticsearch, Kibana,
and other Elastic
Stack features,
allowing you to store,
search, and analyze your data.
We'll name our
deployment Test Deploy
and click the Create
Deployment button
to launch the deployment.
Make sure to save your
deployment credentials.
And when your deployment
is ready, click Continue.
For the purposes
of this tutorial,
we'll work to ingest data from
BigQuery to Elasticsearch.
But please note
that you can also
ingest data from Google
Cloud Storage and Pub/Sub.
We'll go back to Google
Cloud Marketplace and type
in Stack Overflow.
We'll start by ingesting the
popular Stack Overflow data
set.
We'll use a table called
Stack Overflow posts
under the BigQuery data
set, Stack Overflow.
It has several structured
fields as columns,
like post body, title,
comment count, et cetera,
which we'll bring
into Elasticsearch
to perform free text
search and aggregation.
Next step is to create a
Dataflow job from a template.
Visit Dataflow and
then go to Jobs.
Choose Create A Job
from the template.
Choose name, stackoverflowload1,
and keep the default endpoint.
Choose the Dataflow template,
BigQuery to Elasticsearch.
The BigQuery to
Elasticsearch template
is one of Google's
provided templates.
Now fill in the
required parameters,
including your Cloud ID
and base64-encoded API key.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
For the Elasticsearch
index field,
pick an index name where
your data will be loaded.
We'll use the Stack Posts index.
Choose the table and
BigQuery to read from.
We'll use BigQuery Public
Data Stack Overflow Stack
Overflow posts.
Finally, set your
max workers to 1.
Click Run Jobs to start
the batch processing.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
When you visit Kibana,
within a few minutes,
you can see the data flowing
into your Elasticsearch index.
And there you have
it, BigQuery data
ingested into Elasticsearch
with the click of a button.
If you enjoyed this video,
please subscribe and hit
the Like button below.
We encourage you to check
out the GCP Marketplace
and deploy the
solution on your own.
Thanks for watching.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]